[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 hoy jueves 8 de diciembre
Rosa Por supuesto vamos a empezar esta
revista de prensa en Perú con la prensa
internacional que reporta lo sucedido
ayer en el congreso peruano este país y
que cae prácticamente desde el 2016 ha
tenido un presidente por año Buenos días
Raúl exactamente y respecto a lo
sucedido ayer vemos que hay distintas
formas de calificarlo y que cada
cabecera opta por una concepto u otro
empezamos por el Wall Street journal que
con el titular el presidente peruano
destituido tras intentar disolver el
congreso y con el pie de foto que hace
una síntesis parcial de lo ocurrido
vemos a congresistas a celebrando en
Lima tras votar por la destitución del
presidente Pedro Castillo el miércoles
Poco después de que sumiera el país en
el caos cuando anunció que iba a
disolver el legislativo para evitar el
impeachment o la vacancia como se conoce
en Perú vemos que este medio no habla de
golpe pero sin embargo destaca la
noticia en portada vamos ahora con El
Clarín en Argentina un medio más a la
derecha Entonces cómo lo resalta pues lo
enmarca en el siguiente tema del día que
dice a pesar de la conmoción se
preservaron las instituciones y con el
titular el presidente de Perú fue
destituido tras intentar un autogolpe
que duró dos horas como aquí si vemos
esta palabra
autogolpe no también destacan que asumió
la vicepresidenta de inaugularte y que
se convierte por lo tanto en la primera
mujer Eh presidenta jefa de estado del
Perú como son las cosas no a veces
llegar en el momento menos pensado y
vemos que la foto ya es distinta
respecto a la que encontrábamos en la
portada del Wall Street journal y es una
foto que la vemos repetida también
destacada en varios medios de
comunicación y es a Pedro Castillo ya
detenido escuchando los cargos que pesan
sobre él no ha anunciados por la fiscal
del Perú y entre estos cargos que Serían
seis según nos informa Clarín están los
de rebelión y conspiración Así es rosa
seguimos en la región para ver qué dice
el nacional de Venezuela que también
habla de golpe de estado no Pedro
Castillo fue detenido tras dar un golpe
de estado y califica la medida de
desesperada para intentar evitar la
vacancia no sin embargo dice ni las
fuerzas armadas ni el legislativo lo
respaldaron vamos ahora con el país en
España exactamente que aquí encontramos
de nuevo que no se hace una referencia
al término golpe no sino a esto de
disolver El Congreso destituido el
presidente de Perú tras intentar
disolver el congreso y califica la
medida la jugada de castillo de huida
hacia adelante rechazada por todas las
fuerzas incluso por las que le apoyan no
y hay una frase que hemos querido
destacar de Gonzalo banda también en el
país que dice la velocidad de las crisis
peruanas hace que los titulares de hace
minutos sean periódicos de ayer Sin
lugar a dudas No dice muchos países
desearían que los procesos de
destitución fueran tan céles e
implacables como en Perú pero dice
tenemos poco que celebrar en un país en
que hemos visto a pasar seis presidentes
en poco más de lo que dura un periodo
presidencial y señala que el pueblo
peruano sobrevive a pesar de sus
políticas vamos ahora con la prensa
interna Rosa la prensa peruana y
comenzamos con el comercio sí que nos da
algunos detalles de lo que sucedió entre
el momento en que Pedro Castillo emitió
este mensaje a la nación y el momento en
que fue detenido rápidamente dijo que
dice el comercio que Pedro Castillo
llamó al jefe de la de la Policía
Nacional peruana para pedirle su apoyo
sin embargo Raúl Alfaro el jefe de la
policía dijo que no lo apoyaba y que
estaba en contra no del anuncio que
había hecho de esta disolución del
Congreso de decretar el estado de
emergencia y dijo que se quedaba de la
del lado del respecto al Estado de
derecho no hay acto seguido Alfaro
convocó una reunión de alto ni mando de
la policía se concluyó no apoyar lo que
estaba sucediendo tomaron la decisión la
comunicaron al escolta presidencial de
Pedro Castillo le pidieron información
de dónde estaba el presidente que en ese
momento se estaba desplazando a la
embajada de México un comandante de la
policía se desplazó a la embajada de
México otro a la de Cuba y finalmente
fue el propio escolta presidencial de
Castillo quien acabó entregando al ya
expresidente a las autoridades no Y para
acabar con la prensa peruana la
República destaca que es tiempo de la
agenda mínima para el consenso y la
respuesta conjunta a la demanda del país
ha afectado por una crisis interminable
no dice que Baluarte la nueva presidenta
del país necesita este diálogo amplio
que prometió para sacar al país de esta
coyuntura de crisis política gracias a
Rosa como siempre por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa Y
claro que sí vamos a seguir ampliando en
este tema con nuestra primera invitada
del día Rosa Hasta mañana Muchas gracias
Raúl y solo para terminar que no se
quede en el tintero recordar que los
periodistas del New York Times hoy están
en huelga y ese es un tema también
destacadísimo en toda la prensa
internacional un temazo Rosa nosotros
ahora sí pasamos a saludar a nuestra
primera invitada